Hello and happy new year full of
coffee beans (or tea leaves) to
fill your cups with the elixir of
productive work! Speaking of work:
Do you know what does the heavy work for
us when training neural networks? Yes,
it’s optimizers like Stochastic
Gradient Descent or Adam that
decide how much to update the weights
of a neural network during training.
Only that they need the right hyperparameters to
work well and who knows whether to set
the learning rate to 0.001 or 0.0001,
right? Well, you do not need to bother
about optimizer hyperparameters again,
because new work proposes VeLO, a neural network
trained to act as an optimizer that says goodbye
to hyperparameters. It can dynamically decide
what are the best weight updates for your
problem and for your current training step.
It sounds almost too good to be true, right?
In this video, we will explain the VeLO
paper, what VeLO’s limitations are,
and we will find out how a neural network can
behave like an optimizer and how it was trained.
But not before we thank Cohere for sponsoring
today’s video! Since you are watching this video,
we assume you already heard about the incredible
advancements of natural language processing. Maybe
you thought of including the latest and greatest
large language models in your applications? Well,
then Cohere is the right thing for you! It lets
you use extremely capable language models to let
them classify text for you or let them generate
documents. Does this sound complicated? Fear not!
Because it is not at all: Cohere’s specialty is
to take the finest transformer based models like
GPT and BERT and let them do the heavy work
for you under the hood. All you need is to
write these few lines of code to start generating
text; you don’t even need machine learning skills
to use Cohere. Just install with `pip install
cohere` and you are ready to go in Python. So,
what are you waiting for, sign up to Cohere and
start exploring it. They have a very generous
free premium developer tier, so no credits are
needed. Users bear no costs until they go to
production. You can sign up with this link,
also posted in the video description below.
Now back to the optimizers that update the
weights of a neural network during training.
The optimizer determines a new, hopefully better
weight for a neural network by adding
or subtracting a certain value from it.
The SGD optimizer determines
this value to be a fraction of
the gradients of the loss with respect to
the weight. This basically means that we
should go a step into the direction of
steepest descent to minimize the loss.
One very important decision that the optimizer
takes, is to determine how far to move into the
direction that minimizes the loss. If it goes too
far, it can overshoot a minimum. If it goes too
little, the neural network training will take
forever. Here, by using this step size as an
example, we basically explained the learning rate
hyperparameter of SGD. Other optimizers do even
more complicated things than that, for example
they use momentum, in which the weight update
of the current step uses some component of the
update direction from the previous update step.
But it is not the topic of today’s
video to give an overview about the
entire zoo of optimizers. But
keep in mind that there are a
lot of them and there are a lot of
strategies to do the weight updates.
Even worse, each of these little hacks
come with a hyperparameter that decides
how much of this little hack should act
at a certain time step during training,
for example the learning rate can vary
during the training run and you have to
decide upon a learning rate schedule. So, it
is hard to manually decide what is the best
strategy to update the weights for each neural
architecture and for each different dataset.
Therefore, to see how well a set of
hyperparameters do, one needs to do
one whole training run of a network, see how low
the loss gets. Then change the hyperparameters,
and do yet another run. And then another
configuration, and another and so on,
so this becomes really expensive really
fast, until finally, after tens or even
hundreds of runs, we can take the set of
hyperparameters that we saw performed best.
But don’t worry, because this paper proposes VeLO,
which is a learned optimizer that can
do the important decisions on its own
and does not have any hyperparameters! The
idea of this paper is to do meta-learning:
we can use training runs of diverse architectures
and datasets to teach a neural
network to act as an optimizer.
The network would take weight and gradient
information and predict how to update the
weights to minimize the loss of the target
neural network. Of course, this idea is not new,
learned optimizers have been here for around
a while, but no one has trained optimizers
at this scale before and for this range of
tasks, going towards a more general-purpose
optimizer that can be used out-of-the-box
for many datasets and applications.
So how does it work? What do
the authors need to do to train
the VeLO neural network to act as an
optimizer for other neural networks?
First, they need to assemble the training dataset
for VeLO consisting of models of different model
families such as multi-layer-perceptrons,
convolutional networks, residual networks,
transformers, recurrent neural networks,
auto-encoders, variational autoencoders.
These all have different depths,
layer widths and activation functions.
To augment the data, the authors even
do things like reparameterizing the
weights or changing the floating-point precision.
These models are to be trained on tasks ranging
from image classification to image generation,
text generation and training learned
optimizers. Keep in mind the variety
of models and tasks captured by this
training data for VeLO, because the
variety in the training data is highly likely
to determine its capabilities at test time,
because models usually perform well on the type
of settings they have already seen in training and
fail to generalize on tasks out of distribution
(no spoilers, more in this later in the video).
VeLO acts like this: For every single weight, so
for each scalar in the target neural network which
it aims to optimize, at each timestep, it predicts
how much to subtract from the weight to update it.
We say here subtract, but of course that
if it decides to subtract a negative value,
it is like it would have
added something to the weight.
That VeLO applies to each single
weight of the neural net it optimizes,
comes with the advantage that in this way,
it can be applied to any neural network,
independently of its architecture and number
of parameters. But the downside is that it can
become really costly to apply VeLO as the
number of weights increases in a network,
therefore the authors strive
to keep VeLO really small.
Therefore, the lightweight architecture of
VeLO is composed of a per-tensor network and
a per-weight network as follows: The per-tensor
network is an LSTM which takes information about
a parameter tensor. In this way, the authors
make sure that when VeLO predicts an update
value for each parameter, the update is
informed on other weights of the network.
As input the authors use, we cite “the
mean and variance of parameter values,
the exponential moving averages of the gradient
and squared gradient (as used in the Adam update).
The per-tensor network also takes as input a
series of additional features representing the
current fraction of training completed, so that
it can learn training-time dependent strategies,
such as learning rate schedules. Finally, our
per-tensor network has access to the training
loss which can enable complex behaviours
such as detecting divergence of the loss.”
Then the LSTM predicts the weights of a
subsequent network, the per-weight network
which is multi-layer-perceptron or MLP in
short. This MLP is also extremely small,
of just 2 hidden layers with 4 hidden units. This
is the one that uses per-weight information such
as gradients and the value of the weight as input
to predict the update for that weight. Previous
work from the same authors did this differently,
and the MLP took weight information and also the
hidden representation delivered by the LSTM and
learned its own weights. But this made the MLP’s
input larger, therefore slower. So, the authors
decide for the LSTM to train to deliver the
weight of the MLP directly. And we remind you
how important it is to make VeLO lightweight,
since it must do an inference step for each
weight of a neural network during training,
so it’s speed directly affects the training speed
of the target neural network we aim to optimize.
The authors train VeLO to minimize the training
loss at the end of the training of the target
neural network. Yes, and by this we mean that
an entire training run of the target network is
one data point for VeLO. So, getting VeLO to
train and to converge is not a cheap task at
all. The authors need roughly 4 weeks on 1,000 to
5,000 TPUs. Imagine that. But remember that VeLO,
once trained, has no hyperparameter to set because
the whole idea of this learned optimizer is to
figure out by itself what the right strategy for
each training step, model and task is. So, the
authors argue that VeLO’s training cost is minimal
compared to the amount of compute one saves for
not having to train models multiple times to
find the right hyperparameters for optimizers.
So how well does VeLO work in practice? The
already existing benchmark the authors could
use to test VeLO on, was the MLCommons workloads
where on 5 out of 6 tasks, VeLO performed better
than the Adam optimizer which had a hand-tuned
learning rate schedule and weight decay. But to
have a more extensive benchmark that
the authors and future work can use,
this paper also proposes the VeLOdrome
benchmark that encompasses 83 tasks. The
idea of these tasks is to be cheap in terms
of training time, so one can test quickly,
thus the 83 tasks do not need longer
than an hour to train on one GPU.
The other thing is that these tasks should
cover a wide range of architectures, such as
convolutional networks, autoencoders, ResNets,
recurrent neural networks and transformers.
The good news is, that VeLO performs really
well on these tasks, even when compared to
powerful optimizers such as NAdamW that
had hand-tuned hyperparameters from more
than 1000 training runs. So VeLO, that
does not have any hyperparamters could
outrun NAdamW out-of-the-box and get better
performance in 85% of the cases. And it got
there faster than Adam. On half the VeLOdrome
tasks it was even 4 times faster than Adam.
But these good results on
VeLOdrome are a bit expected,
since the VeLOdrome benchmark contains exactly
the kind of settings that VeLO was trained on:
this variety of architectures
and short training runs.
So unsurprisingly, VeLOs limitations stand
at long training runs of more than 200,000
training steps or for large models that have more
than 500 million parameters. On the one hand, it
fails exactly where hyperparameter search
becomes more costly: in long training runs
and on large models. But at least it means that
VeLO can help in the most standard applications,
which are also the ones needed more often in
practice. And that VeLO underperforms in large
training regimes is not necessarily the end of the
story but makes us hopeful for the future where
TPU’s won’t start screaming in panic that a single
data point for a network is the entire training
run of another network. So, there you have it,
this was Ms. Coffee Bean’s summary of the exciting
VeLO paper that proposes to train optimizers from
data rather than hand-tuning hyperparameters.
Thanks for watching and see you next time!
Okay, bye!